this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
well we have uh Ron Perlman it's a big
one for me yeah Hellboy and Hellboy it
is trying to play it cool here but
here's here's the thing as an actor I've
been doing this for 30 years isn't it as
an actor it's very important to let me
speak on on Ron over here because wait
well can I have one more thing yes you
know he's the voice of the UFC I did not
know that I did not know that education
I did not know that no the message
that was my Ace of my sleeve I was you
know I love that I was going to play
that card Down the Road a Piece the man
the man has had the man has had as as
story to career
as it gets there's no actor in the
planet if when you're starting out if
you said do you want a career like Ron
Perlman everybody I'll take I'll take
that I'll take it right away okay but
here's what's here's what's interesting
here's what people don't talk about he
does it and has always done it
without really moving he barely even
moves his mouth
like the guy just kind of sits there and
says a couple things I just said and you
don't really hear the New York that much
but he doesn't move as much he doesn't
[__] move his mouth it's called
talent and you know what here's but
here's why here's the thing about being
a great actor
he I believe everything he says all the
time it's kind of that Gene Hackman
thing he's never done anything I've seen
and I've seen probably everything you've
done I'm sorry to hear that I know we've
all done some terrible stuff but for the
most part you've done some great stuff
I've never seen you have a moment where
I that I didn't believe you and to be
that still and be able to do that for
that long is so much harder than people
realize but so much but also run didn't
I hear at one point you're gonna quit or
get out of the game you you're going
auditions weren't getting a lot of
things then you got was it Beauty and
the Beast and you wanna you won awards
for that but you were thinking about
getting out
well the business thought I was out
on a couple of occasions I had to keep
checking my phone to see if I hadn't
paid the bill because it was it didn't
ring for like three years and it was
funny because it was right after like in
nineteen
eighty seven Beauty and the Beast hit
the airwaves and ran for two and a half
seasons and then we they canceled it at
the beginning of 19 the new guy that
took over CBS you know you know they
swore him in
and he took the oath of office you know
to like uphold the CBS Constitution yeah
and his first official Act was Beauty
and the Beast canceled out
no no no last game later this was Jeff
Jeff somebody or another he ended up in
can't have that I didn't create it so
get it out of here he ended up he ended
up launching this religious Network you
know that did all his Christian shows
and [__] which good luck with that I
mean you know he never called me because
I was busy you know saying that my
Brokers is he being Jewish but um uh
Jeff something I'll remember his [__]
name
no grudge is held Jeff no no you know
you know we're good bro we're good okay
I better not run into you but anyway
um what was that oh yes so what was his
question
you know I there was only one moment
in my
from the time I started acting in high
school
to today
there was only one moment where I was
gonna give it up and it was like long
time ago it was in this 70s probably
um and it and it and it only lasted for
a day and a half that's good because I
decided on a Tuesday
um
I I I'm not getting any signals that I
should keep doing this there's not one
person and I'm not even sure
I'm giving myself signals but definitely
nobody else's and you know this is too
hard a thing to do without
a little signal from the universe like
okay keep bearing it against the wall
because eventually you know there were
no signals there was so that was a
Tuesday my buddy got tickets to a play
um a Revival of a Tennessee Williams
play called sweet bird of Youth great
play with Christopher Walken and Irene
worth irony worth is a was a an
incredible English character actress
and the curtain comes up and I watch
Irene worth give this tour de force
performance she acts rings around
Christopher Walken it was all he could
[__] do to keep up he was great but
she was like yeah a Dynamo
and we got in the car after the play me
and my buddy Burton we started driving
home we'd gotten about 45 minutes into
the trip and he says
why are you so [__] quiet
I said there's nothing I can say after
that performance I said that she just
razzled and dazzled my ass like up and
down
and then I the first thing I actually
said was you know what what she just did
to me
whatever I got to do whatever fire I
gotta walk through to maybe do that to
somebody else it's worth it and I've
never ever had a moment that happened to
me with Raging Bull when I saw De Niro
whatever happened to me I went I got you
know and you but when you see great
theater in New York though when you see
great actors like I saw I watch Death of
a Salesman with Brian Denny and Gloria
uh remember her yeah bro I I was like I
literally was like well first of all
what am I doing because that's where the
bar is
and it just changes you it changes your
DNA and all you want to do is maybe
participate in that magic for a couple
of seconds so you can and what happens
to an audience I think when you watch
something like that is you forget you're
human for a while and what I mean by
that is you forget you have to go to the
bathroom have sex eat sleep
you are an arrested High Relief you are
suddenly transported to something which
is something probably close to what I
would consider God where you kind of go
that's the highest truth I can imagine I
guess you're dealing with beauty you're
dealing with something that kind of
transports you into what is actually
truly important and everything else
seems trivial did you see Jerusalem do
you see Mark rylance in Jerusalem I did
not know one of my besties though Kim
coach just did a Revival of that and uh
so he was telling me about what a total
force that is that's what Spielberg saw
and said I got to put him in my
again you see these
who did Spielberg see Mark rylance oh
yes you see these athletes when you see
these actors on stage who are doing
eight shows a week for two and a half
hours sometimes and hitting their marks
every time and and
you they're they're physically they're
physically athletic correct me if I'm
right and they're not it's not like
they're millionaires doing every night
like on Broadway they're not getting
paid crazy money that guy never he was
never making money I don't think he's
making money now oh there it is yeah
that's really cool how you brought that
up man this is great that's yeah
yeah I was in a movie with him about a
year and a half ago called don't look up
um which um Adam McKay wrote and
directed and it was the greatest cast of
actors I've ever
participated with was Leo and Jennifer
Lawrence and Meryl Streep and you know
not a lot of people you've heard of
there it is this don't look up wow and
Mark rylance acted everybody else off
the [__] screen really I mean I
just of all you know I'm a fan of all
these people I mean I'm just I'm just
such a movie geek still to this point
but watching Mark rylance do what he did
in that movie I went
I could never I I would never be able to
have the imagination to come up with a
character like that and then execute it
so because it's two phases always it's
like first the imagination gets fired up
and you start
imagining a piece of humanity that you
that you've had to glom off off some
words on a page
and then you you get that of humanity
and
I I I I actually have identified two
periods in my acting career the first
one was I was able to identify the
humanity
but my execution of it was always it
stopped at the identification stage I
didn't get into the flow stage of it all
um and I realized that I I kept watching
my work and I kept going that's very
technically correct but you're not
flowing you're not in the moment and so
it became an obsession for me to like
just
forget about the imagination part of it
forget about the concept part of it just
when the camera's rolling have the balls
to just float and see what comes out
and it's been a comment so that so the
one thing informs the other so but Mark
rylance plays this guy who's very much
like Steve Jobs I guess you know and uh
you got to just go back and watch the
performance watch him in anything he's
riveting and you were sitting in the car
quiet I love that story because you kind
of went I gotta I gotta do this I gotta
figure out how to how to do to somebody
what that woman did to me or you know I
I gotta not look back I gotta never ever
doubt that this is worth
whatever I got to go through to do it
because the effect she had on me
and I remember when I was a kid you know
when I fell in love with movies I was
like my dad was uh
a laborer lower lower middle class
Jewish guy from New York
carried a 35 pound tool box
went house to house fixing people's
televisions for three dollars a house
call when everybody else was charging 15
my dad was kind of you know he was like
a kind of a role model but his life was
not you know not easy fettered with with
luxury yeah but what he did do was he
surrounded himself he surrounded himself
with
music and and and movies and New York
Yankees that was those are his three
Passions
uh and
um I would watch him
um you know come home from work we'd
have dinner around seven seven thirty
this thing called million dollar movie
would come on on Channel 9 in New York
WR in New York and I would watch him
watch the Tyrone Power performance
and I'd look in his face and there'd be
tears in his eyes and and he was he was
infused with he was transported
to
um where I don't know but then I kept
going from his face to the screen to his
face to the screen watching him watch
Spencer Tracy and Errol Flynn and John
Wayne you know and all those great John
Ford movies and everything like that and
my dad without having any feel for
uh uh you know a
appreciation of Cinema like one one does
when one commits to it as a profession
he was he he was [__] Hook Line and
Sinker man transported into a better
place
next [__] morning get up and carry
that 35 pound thing again he do what he
had to do to put food on the table but
at night it was Sinatra or the Yankees
when the season was happening or a
million dollar movie and
um that's where I got my like
you know not only did I get a a a a love
for what movies could do to to an
average working stiff
but also I grew up on the main streets
in New York City right
and I was a Jewish guy in an Irish
Puerto Rican Italian
black neighborhood yeah no fights there
yeah they're nice too I mean just
walking to school it wasn't anything in
particular it was all of the above right
you know so you're the Jews
you got to pretend you're Italian a lot
of Jewish kids pretend they were Italian
they're like I I did of course of course
let's get to that I'll get to that but
but I basically that's where I learned
how to be funny because if somebody said
I'm gonna [__] kick your ass up I
would tell them a joke and that would be
how I would describe yeah but um where
was that going with this so you talk
about growing up in the Mean Streets of
New York yeah yeah here's my point
you know you you come to terms when you
grow up in a in a high a high pressure
environment like New York City and
you're a young kid and you're fighting
for your life and you know you're trying
to figure out like in the in the in the
in the food chain right where the [__]
do I fit you know I'm a fat Jewish kid
right and I'm surrounded by guys who
just wanted to kill me
and so where do I fit and how do I how
do I survive this
you would think that that was where you
would learn how to become a man where I
learned how to become a man
was watching
John Wayne's walk
Errol Flynn Swagger Tyrone Powers charm
Jimmy Cagney's [__] manhood
um Humphrey Bogart's weirdness in terms
of his man I learned everything I needed
to know about
the kind of man that I wanted to grow up
to be from movies yeah really yes and
I'm not I'm not saying that because
that's the value it's the value of great
story though because you you watch you
watch these guys
who are all flawed in these in these
pictures but who had a challenge where
they had to rise to hero hero Hood
and there were huge amounts of obstacles
that got in their way but one way or
another you were watching them
push it aside for the greater good
that's what a hero is in a movie do you
remember angels with dirty faces oh my
God right and Jimmy Cagney who was
famous for saying acting's easy all you
got to do is hit your mark look the
other actor in the eye and tell the
truth right boom and the angels are
dirty faces the reason he just went oh
my God and you talk about A Life Lesson
and talk about giving up what you want
for what you need and and coming up with
new equilibrium as a human being he
plays this he he and these he plays this
criminal and he has a life of crime and
his best friend was a priest and and the
reason he couldn't he got caught and his
friend didn't was because he couldn't
run as fast so his friend who ran fast
ran away from the law he became a priest
Jimmy Cagney gets caught because he
couldn't run as fast he gets put in
juvenile detention caught up in the
system becomes a criminal and a hero
among the kids in the neighborhood he's
like gangster yeah and he gets he kills
somebody and the priest comes to him and
says I want you going to the chair
you're going to the electric chair and
Jimmy gagne is going to bring me to the
chair I'll go to the chair like a man
you know I'm not gonna I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna I don't need a priest get out
of here you know I'm gonna go like a man
and I'm going to show him who I am and
the priest says I don't want you to do
that
I want you to do me one last favor and I
know you're gonna hate this but I want
you to do me one last favor go ahead
that's what he says I want you to do one
last favor I know you're going to hate
it he says what is it and he goes I want
you to go to the chair like a coward oh
wow I want you to go kicking and
screaming and crying because I don't
want these kids to look up to you yes
and he goes that's all I got all I got
is my is my manhood you're taking that
away from me the last minute get out of
here I'm not doing it that's all I got
and he kind of looks at him and he goes
like this he goes and he and the priest
leaves the cell
you know basically the son of a [__]
I'm not doing that [__] and then they
take them and the way they shoot it is
you see just his Shadows him his shadow
and the guard shadow on the wall as
they're taking him
and you think he's just gonna be like I
got it I got it I got it like that and
then you see him go please don't don't
hey man please I'm afraid don't and they
grab and then you see the kid
neighborhood kids uh uh what's his name
goes to the chair yella in other words
he goes like a coward it's cool and
they're all disappointed and uh the
priest says come on boys let's go to
church and say a prayer yeah yeah a kid
who couldn't run as fast it's a that
movie
that's an example of we go to the
theater
to laugh and cry here's my question my
question is you you had those Heroes
that molded your life you had yours
there it is right there and I had mine
as a kid like the reels got like showed
you how to be a man and like carry
yourself and you know have morals stuff
like that you look at the the Stars
today you know I have two young boys who
do they have to look up to in your
business good question buddy who do they
have taking a little break with one of
my face Hellboy Ron Perlman because the
NFL is here college football is here my
CU Buffs play Oregon they're 18 point
dogs but we are back with another week
of NFL football draftking sports book is
keeping us in on the NFL action with
great offers every single game day
Thursday Night Football Saturday College
Sunday NFL Monday Night Football new
customers can bet five dollars and get
200 instantly in bonus bets throw down
five on any of this week's epic matchups
to walk away an instant winner and
DraftKings isn't stopping there all
customer can take advantage of two new
offers every day this September
football's more fun when you're in on
the action so download the app now sign
up with the code fighter new customers
combat just five buckaroos to get 200
instillion bonus bets only on DraftKings
Sportsbook an official Sports button
partner of the NFL the code Fighter the
crown is yours gambling problem called
100 gambling or if it's
www.1800cambler.net in New York called
The 8778 Hope and wire text Hope NY 467
369 in Connecticut help is available for
problem gambling call
888-789-7777 or visit
ccpg.org please play responsibly on
behalf of Boot Hill Casino and Resort KS
21 plus age varies by jurisdiction avoid
in Ontario c c
dkng.com dot Co slash football for
eligibility terms and responsible gaming
resources bonus bets expire seven days
after issuance eligibility and deposit
restrictions apply DraftKings Bronco
fighter go Buffs listen sometimes you
get an accident sometimes you're out of
work perhaps sometimes you need money
but okay and then sometimes you're like
I don't want to sue the person but guess
what a lot of times you're not suing the
person most of the time you're suing the
insurance company yeah dude secondly
ever injured Brian you can check out
Morgan and Morgan tell me more about
Morgan and Morgan is that the America's
largest injury Law Firm yeah dude over
100 offices Nationwide more than 8
hundred lawyers with over 15 billion
with a B recovered for over 300 000
clients Morgan Morgan has a proven track
record all right Morgan Morgan has been
fighting for the people for over 35
freaking years yeah but is it hard to
submit an injury claim it's too easy
it's too you do it from your phone yeah
the whole thing don't be scared just
some clicks yep if you're ever injured
you can check out Morgan Morgan their
fee is free unless you win for more
information go to forthepeople.com
fighter or dial pound law that's
pound529 from your cell that's for the
people.com fighter or pound law pound529
from your cell this is a paid
advertisement good question buddy who do
they have that's what's up Timothy
yeah huh poor bastard
respect for you I didn't want to fire
back because I was like oh wait yeah
yeah they're all gonna grow up to be
Edward Scissorhands like [__] freaks
you know like God Freaks and [__] you
know guys who wear lipstick and you know
that's you know what do you do it's like
I feel bad me too I feel bad like you
know I I I I feel bad I don't I don't
really want to you know if I if I
elaborate too hard you'll get cancel I'm
gonna throw a lot of people under a lot
of [__] buses and I don't think I
really want to do that because I love
actors and I love acting so much and
it's not so much
um the
The Human Condition that has changed
and this is my big big big thing across
the board
what has changed in our society are the
things that the people in charge are
having us worship
so what has changed is the marketplace
so like I'm you know I have two kids who
who write it and execute music and you
know they were my daughter was five
years too late and my son was ten years
too late because if they had come along
prior to that
they would have put on they would have
played in some Club
some record executive would have seen
him spent a million dollars on
creating an album and doing a publicity
campaign and putting them out into the
world setting up a tour and boom they'd
be living in Bel Air in a [__]
Mansion because their music was great
now do you think there's any less of
those people around you think that
there's no Stevie Wonder being born
every day but he can't get to the
marketplace because [__] you know
Napster came along and devalued
everybody's [__] contribution yep so
nobody has a shot
to to to to live in that beautiful old
model it's not that the talents changed
what has changed is the marketplace is
the way the talent gets to emerge and it
seems to me that a song or anything like
that is consumed like it's a it's a
nugget to consume it's it's a dopamine
hit you know remember when when we were
growing up
when
Led Zeppelin or Aerosmith or whoever it
was came out with an album you took your
you saw the album there was an art to
the album you listen to every song There
was a a side and a b side and it was a
body of work that you took into context
it was actually even thematic the way
they would arrange the songs because
they knew we were gonna and there was a
physical aspect to it you had to I
remember my dad taking care of the uh
keep the dust cover on the turntable
yeah yeah there was there was a delicacy
and it meant something it was a big
thing to go by the album but now but
also the reason they did that is they
made their money based off those album
sales now music artists like Drake and
those guys that are the streaming they
don't make much of streaming they make
their money off live touring and merch
yes so that there's no value in putting
that great artistic effort into sweet
album cover or a hard album because it's
out they stream it and then the kids
move on
there was a there was a kind of a
mysticism when a new album would come
out and you'd have to wait sometimes six
months or a year for one of your
favorite artists to put something out
and like you say you'd be the first one
online to get the album you take it home
you'd lift up the cover of your of this
beautiful piece of of
uh phonograph to you know whatever
whatever it was you were listening to
that you spent your whole life saving up
for to get the greatest [__] sound
you had the woofers and the tweeters and
you know yeah and and you'd play this
that you'd smoke a couple of Bones and
you'd play this [__] thing mine would
be blown and you'd play it over and over
and over again and that thing would take
a place in your life and also in society
where it became this this aspirational
vehicle that everybody just said oh [__]
man I'm gonna work my ass off to to make
something happen that sounds like that
it was easy so it created more
generations of people who were doing who
were wanting to do the same thing but it
was because there was a kind of a a
mystical kind of
uh preciousness to the the process and
they weren't just like
they weren't just streaming 85 million
shows a night correct and none of them
had any different value than the other
80 80 83
000 you know that's what's happened
everything's become
the the the the the
preciousness of each thing having an
individual value has been removed
because they're just throwing [__] out
just on it yeah throwing mud at a while
they're throwing [__] out is that
happening with movies you think totally
it is huh totally I did a you know the
movie I just referred to
I did two movies that played on Netflix
over the last two years one of them was
don't look up
and the other one was Pinocchio
and both of them got multi-nominations
you know they both played on Netflix
they both were great for a week
trending for one week
mention their names to anybody there you
go it's so true what movie was that I
know where is their massive words for
those weeks man number one on Netflix
yeah but then a week goes by there's a
new crop whereas when we still had you
know the
have you walked into like
the lowest Paradise in New York or Radio
City Musical those were Cathedrals that
were built for people to go watch movies
in that's how much Grandeur it's true
and Majesty our culture had when it was
not all just boiled down into like how
many [__] you know stock options we
can get because they want subscribers so
they're getting as much content as
possible just put it all out whether
it's good or bad they don't care it all
sits next to each other it all speaks
nice job but also it's happening in
common we all feel in our in our field
and stand up so so Shane girls number
one special great special no more
special you have a week now it's not
like when Eddie Murphy drops a special
George Carlin where you're talking about
it for the next two three years we're
even talking about Eddies now yeah now
think about it some of these great
specials you have a weak man a week and
then so to my why do it well I guess if
you get the patient from that values we
all feel devalued we all feel I think
the the we all of us feel like there may
be no place for this biology for this
you know when you're writing I was up at
3 30 last night because I watched
Michelle Wolf's I want you to watch her
her episode two and three of her special
phenomenal so she's great she's so well
crafted at jokes but I got inspired and
I woke up and I wrote from three
to 5 30 and you know as well as I do
writing a good one hour of Comedy I'm on
tour right now you know it's so
difficult because you have to it takes
you it takes me two years before I shoot
my special and I got a tour and I gotta
carve it and then I come back and I go
that was [__] or I add something to
it but it takes so much of my thought
and like I always wonder like is it
worth it because they're going to watch
it as a clip on on Instagram and that's
good for that and then on to my next
dopamine hit and it doesn't even nobody
even has the time to sit through an hour
if I shoot an hour of Comedy are you out
of your mind who's gonna sit through
that nobody has the attention span
anymore no even though Bill both feel
valued even with Bill Burr like you when
when I spoke to Netflix like I don't
care who special it is if people stop
watching doesn't matter Kevin Hart at
the 20 if you're like Kevin Hart level
Bill Bird level they stop watching the
28 minute mark
28 minutes that's a and that you know
you got to figure that's the average so
some people are watching but the general
28 minutes long time but for an hour
special so it's like so then why are we
still putting out 60. we know they're
not even getting to that that's your
model yeah it's crazy because he used to
pay different because it's worth it
because we love it because we we we
don't think like like you know
you know the only reason why they know
it's like 28 minutes everybody stops is
because
they're [__] lawyers yeah the guys
who came from [__] hedge funds yeah
they're nice because they have no
education and no taste or numbers and no
ability to know what's good or bad all
they have is algorithm that's it so you
get you get these guys who like oh yeah
we'll figure out like what the public
wants by by executing our algorithm yeah
and that's how we know oh after 28
minutes you know I'm sorry you're
valueless yeah it's so true so I'm only
going to pay you for 28 minutes because
here I I have it right in my I have the
the numbers you're not worth anything
after 28 minutes so you know that hour I
was going to pay you for I'm only going
to pay you for 10 half yeah dude you're
so right about that you you are that's
the way they think we're all reduced to
a number every one of us is reduced
seriously like how many butts you put in
the seat how many clicks you get I get
the capitalist market system I get it
and I'm I I believe in that but it's not
capitalists capitalism
or any ISM any ideology is only as good
as the people who are executing it and
if the people who are executing are
Philistines who have absolutely no
relationship to the beauty of culture to
the things that you and I are talking
how do we get here how do we switch it
because now ai's we tear it down now the
AI is coming in we tear it down and we
rebuild it we rebuild it in the image of
the 99 because the people who we're
talking about who are making all these
[__] positions and using all the
algorithm that's the one percent yeah
and they got us both less than one
person they got us [__] they control
everything yeah well you know what
[__] maybe you don't control
everything yeah maybe it's us they don't
have the power maybe you stop maybe we
Gaslight you yeah for a change [__] I'll
storm Netflix with you right now I know
you got me fired up dude how much do you
like Ron Perlman
I wasn't enjoying this conversation so
like what what you're doing Ron is
you're you're talking about the things
that matter and that are important and I
just find myself wanting to be nowhere
else and that's interesting to me that I
have that emotional reaction because
you're touching on things that we
oftentimes
forget because I'm so busy making a
living and I'm so busy hustling and
you'll be caught up in the business of
the algorithm and it never dawned on me
but it's all but it's tough because you
came from Kansas City or let's say you
post a clip you look at the numbers
because we we're all conditioned but God
bless you because you're not just making
a living you're actually expressing
yourself yes and the living will follow
from that yeah and we all get caught up
in the fact that you know the the the
the the the more wealth we're able to
accrue the more independent we get so
wealth has a really important yeah I'm
not complaining we've done well so I'm
not I'm very but it's important because
what you want you you don't want to have
to depend on anybody you want to have
autonomy you want to have Independence
and you want to have a certain sort of a
a [__] you kind of uh a distance from
yes from being completely co-opted by
the asset yes right yes so so being
successful is important
but really what what what you are
protecting
the three of us who are sitting here I
don't know about these [__]
I don't trust them either but but the
three of us were Superior because
because we yes we all want to be
successful we all want to you know we
all care about
um reaching the most people why because
we are creative people who want to keep
expressing ourselves and making comments
about the lives we're living in which is
what culture is yeah and
I I will fight that I will I will die on
that hill and in fact
the strike
um to make an awkward segue I love it
tell us a good Segway can you explain
for the people what this strike is
really about and and what what uh what
we're fighting for writers and actors
artists
I think what what happened to me
with the onset of the strike
was uh strangely gradual
strangely gradual
not very gradual because after the first
week I was where I am right now but it
took me a week to realize and it took me
this strike to realize how broken
the the
relationship with between the
impresarios who make
our culture you know possible and those
of us who create the how how vast the
disconnect has become
and um can I just stop you it's really
important point you made I always say
that that uh the Cornerstone of a
culture the Cornerstone of a culture any
culture is its artistic expression when
you think about India you think about
the Taj Mahal that was built by uh Raj
for he wanted to impress a lady you know
when you think about England you think
about Shakespeare when you think about
America you think about rock and roll
you think about jazz you think about
those things that we export that's what
people want to be closest to that's what
makes people feel alive and anybody who
doesn't understand how important art is
to our literal identity it is what we
stay alive for it's what we live for you
know so sorry to interrupt but I just
wanted to highlight that because I think
it's really important it's kind of what
you're talking about it is this famous
story
um and I'm I'm probably not going to get
it exactly right because I'm I only
anecdotally heard it and
um
I didn't hear it quoted directly from Mr
Churchill but during the London Blitz
during World War II you know when London
was getting our finest Hour the the crap
knocked out of them they went to Mr
Churchill and they said Mr Churchill
we're going to have to black out
the city because we're a Sitting Duck
here he said what do you mean and they
said well you know we have to have to
close the Opera Houses and the theaters
and and and we have to shut everything
down
he said well then what is it we're
fighting for
if
so damn
they kept it all over exactly right bro
and and he he [__] wrote it out he
said I'm not shutting down the lights of
my city
that's the lights of my city you if I if
I shut the lights of my city down they
win the things that make life worth
living which is hearing an incredibly
beautiful Aria or watching barishnikov
defy gravity or watching Tennessee
Williams like make you go holy [__] you
know then the enemy has won that's right
that's right they've taken our music
away they've taken they've won because
they're Philistines they're Savages and
they have no regard for anything and
just numbers those poor bastards their
lives are what are you even doing alive
[__] you go kill yourself man if you if
you if you if if there's nothing in your
life that's worth living for and dying
for accept anger and and some sort of
Twisted theocracy
get the [__] out of my way bro you know
get the [__] out of here you know so uh
so I I interrupted you before I went off
on my thing about that yeah because you
were saying there's this you were
talking about the strike and what is
this disconnect between the impresarios
and and
it doesn't seem like we're moving close
closer to the goal line seems like it's
getting further and further away but
what what you would know better than
anybody what what has shocked my
sensibilities
um and I think everyone else is because
I'm hearing a lot of people now
um who are getting the joke about
the um runaway greed of the people who
are on the other side of the operating
of the negotiating team they're not even
on the other side of the negotiating
table they won't come to the negotiating
table because they're using this
opportunity
as to diabolically prove to the world
that they're just nothing but
Charles Dickens villains wow because
they they have respect for nothing other
than next quarters
profits and their stock options
and
you know
um
we we all thought who the [__] would
dare on the heels of a pandemic
not only allow a strike to happen
but
take the position like
we're just gonna [__] starve you out
they started out
the conversation with we're just we're
gonna wait for people to start losing
their houses that's what they said
really yes that's what they said they
said we're going to wait until people
start losing their houses and having to
worry about their rent is these freaking
people because that because they know
that they can do that but you know to me
they don't know anybody they don't know
anybody in Hollywood unless you know
what you're dealing with these days oh
finally you said the quiet part out
there you go yeah
oh thank you thank you for revealing who
it is we're we're negotiating with you
know what Beast you're dealing with so
uh
um
it took me
a really short amount of time to realize
regardless of what we get when the
strike is finally over with
it's we're still in the exact same
position of dealing in a world where
they're trying to devalue
our worth
to make their worth more worth it it's
not the mercy nothing really changes you
might have some more favorable terms but
that's the machine it also might be too
that they are looking at the the fact
that the world of art has become
something you consume like candy and it
goes back to what we were talking about
they're like listen dude you're
replaceable I can replace you but
replace you with what that's what's
scary I don't know an aim that's what
I'm saying
yeah and they might even say this too
people don't really care about great
movies anymore they're so awesome
they just want popcorn stuff they want
we can export this China and make our
money they're off on the AI too they
think people are going to go to a movie
theater knowing it's not the it's not
Ron you can't replace him you're screwed
you can't replace it they're going to
learn the hardware you can't replace I
always say this about great movies too
the amount first of all there's so many
moving parts so so the the alchemy that
has to occur the the beautiful accident
that has to occur when you see a movie
like The Godfather or whatever it might
be any movie that moves you but also
like don't get it twisted great acting
great directing great writing is a craft
that is as difficult as anything you can
think about and requires respect and a
work ethic that is that is as I'll put
it up against anything great directors
great storytellers great acting it ain't
an accident but again to his point they
they don't they don't look at it like
that yep how long does it take you
before you felt like you were an actor
you were probably always felt like an
actor but but when you felt like you
were able to navigate a role with the
BET you've worked with the best of the
best
the best of the best so when you come to
that set with Meryl Streep and yeah
there's some insecurities wrong are you
like [__] let me tell you a little quick
little anecdote so a shooting don't look
up in Boston
in uh December January and February of
2021 2020 and 2021 so we're in the heart
of the lockdown
and there were certain pictures that
were
that were you know they had to spend a
lot of money to have the covet testing
to have the thing and to have the
lockdown to make sure that actors were
staying you know in their hotel rooms
and everything like that but I I
actually went to work on a couple of
things right in the heart of the
lockdown don't look up was one of them
and so most of the scenes I do and don't
look up I'm all by myself I'm in a
spaceship and all you know but I had one
scene where I had where the president
United States played by Meryl Streep
introduces me as the guy who's gonna go
up and and fight the asteroid and uh it
was a night shoot so I left my hotel it
was February it was 27 degrees
Fahrenheit I left my hotel room
um at around 3 30 in the afternoon
because we had like an hour and a half
drive and then we had a rehearse and
then by the time the sun went down we
were going to start shooting and I had
stolen a washcloth from the bathroom in
my hotel room
and I get in it's 27 degrees I get in
the the van the teamster picks me up
and I'm only in a t-shirt I got a shirt
and I got my winter coat alongside me
and I'm I'm wiping my my face and and
the guy keeps looking in the rearview
mirror like going uh oh Jesus Christ
it's like
and he says to me uh
you want me to turn the heat down I said
no no it's okay and I'm I'm he's looking
at me in the rearview mirror and I'm I'm
convinced he thinks I got covert
because I am you were nervous I am
sweating bullets
and finally he says to me
how you doing back there I said I'm good
I'm good I'm good no you were right you
seem like
you're sweating and you're all like you
are you okay I go yeah he says what's
the problem I said Meryl Streep
I mean I had not only not ever met her
but I never thought that I was gonna
have to go toe-to-toe on a in a scene
with her and she's like
she occupies this she might be the
greatest actor actor period in some ways
you could make where I live she's she's
in that conversation she's the goat yeah
yeah and so uh he goes what do you mean
I go never mind you never understand but
uh yeah he's like he's like all right
but I was I had [__] rolling down my
legs at the thought that I was gonna
have to now that was what two years ago
yeah I was 71 years old bro
so you're asking me like when did I when
did I realize that when did I realized
that I was as good as any of them I
still haven't and I never will look at
that cast right there look at that yeah
wow you know how recently not not when
you shot Hellboy which is one of my
favorite movies but
now Martin Martin sorcity said it he
goes I don't view that as art the the
the the comic book stuff it's just not
my cup of tea you know more power to
them it's not what I don't consider that
real you know art as far as what I do I
wouldn't make those pictures and I
thought about you I'm like well Hellboy
is such a different thing but it is a
comic book movie Hellboy it's a comic
book is a massive comic book when you
did it though that wasn't the narrative
was there any reservations not taking
that role oh [__] no you didn't know why
that's a bro game chance Life Changes
life changing you played that character
you did your own thing with that
character like you were playing that was
crazy like barely again again uh uh uh a
badass Superhero by the way I want to
know how long you were in makeup for
that
so on an average day I was in makeup for
four hours but then if you notice on the
far right well the Far Far Right is
David [__] Harbor I don't know what
the [__] you're putting him up there
on the lower left is me shirtless those
days were six hours
um wow
now now how much CGI is there how much
makeup no CGI whatsoever that's pure
it's practical
they just pay them no I'm saying your
body though you you're you're you're
you're kind of a strong dude well it was
six hours because four of those hours of
me doing sit-ups
so exactly and then I went David Harbor
up there yeah
I don't get off this bus yeah I don't
trust these guys you know you played
them with such humor though that
character you just there was something
about that character it was just great
well here's what happened it says teases
Hellboy 3 Is that real or is that just I
I I'll tease anything you like
give it to me give it to me I'm like
every character ever in New York I'm
just trying to make a living that's it
um what was what were you saying about
it if you look at the when when Gamo
first made Hellboy One
the readership of the Hellboy comics
with 6 000 readers worldwide
it was not a particular it was it was it
was not yeah it wasn't a like Marvel it
was not like like DM was it a Batman
yeah it was this little one horse comic
book Dark Horse Comics and 6 000
worldwide so
it was a bit of a a you know uh uh an
uphill battle
to to do something that wasn't
pre-branded sure like when you do Batman
it's it's so branded already so you you
know your your marketing campaigns but
this was
and then in the comic books
Hellboy only spoke in like one word
sentences he would go oh or yep or you
know so when Guillermo had to make him
three-dimensional as a movie character
he needed a model
around which to create the humanity you
know and since Hellboy was
um a cigar smoking beer drinking
um underachiever who only wanted to stay
in his bunker and watch Marx Brothers
movies and he baby play with his cats
and eat pizza he said I'm just gonna
model this off Promenade because he's
he's such a degenerative did you get
offered the role well he fought for me
to have the role for seven years wow the
studio he he took five years in one
studio and they finally said
sorry we're never going to make this as
long as you keep saying around from his
name we're never going to make this he
goes so he let he let he let the
contract with universal lapse and then
spent another two years trying to sell
me for the role
and everybody says look we got nothing
against Perlman but he he can't be the
star of a franchise he's like a schlub
you know he's like just like you know
he's like a character actor on a good
day he's a character
um but what a genius he is because now I
can't picture you not being no what a
genius he's not straight into heaven not
only not only the the you know the the
the vision of who he wanted to play the
role but the the single-mindedness of
letting yeah of of letting his movie not
get made rather than making it the way
he didn't want it what was the we need
more people oh he saw you in that
convinced him you'd be good for help
well I was in his very first movie it
was called Kronos it was a Mexican film
it was like a tiny little budget and we
got along like we became Bros on that
film great guy he's a great guy yes he
just got along so [__] good and then
he took me along with everything he did
he put me in Blade Two
um and then and all the while
he was trying to get Hellboy made and he
kept telling the studios
this is how I see it and I kept saying
Guillermo I said you know Hellboy is um
too good a project for you to not make
and I said if you make it with somebody
else I won't be mad I get it I get how
the business works of course so you know
don't speaking of Hills to not die on
them you know like just go make your
movie he goes yes my friend I will I
will do that and he was lying to me you
know he was just like no I'm not gonna
make it unless I make it away when he
called you one day and said I got you
the you're so what he did was
when Blade Two got made
Blade Two
opened at 42 million dollars for the
opening weekend and the Monday after the
opening weekend everyone in town said
the Guillermo
we want to be in the business with you
what movie do you want to make and he
said I knew at that point I was either
going to get it done or not and he said
I want to do Hellboy and my caveat as I
want Ron Perlman and they said okay how
did it do some sucker said okay yeah it
did okay yeah it didn't lose money yeah
it wasn't uh like Iron Man but it's a
cult it's a cult classic I feel like
people everybody it's on TV all the time
yeah they play oh one of those movies
that just stood the test of time yeah no
it's very we're all really proud to have
been to have done it and you got a
second film uh you know and and it was
uh designed to be a Trilogy which we've
never made the third one but I'm still
fighting for that what about what about
uh Sons of Anarchy yeah that was after
it did it went Hellboy and then you
rolled into Sons of Anarchy so all right
we did
so yeah
when Hellboy 2
was in the can and getting ready to come
out
uh that's when um they were they were
talking about Sons of Anarchy and uh
um
I guess I got on a short list of guys to
play you know Clay Morrow and uh met
with Kurt Sutter the the creator of the
show we had we saw eye to eye on the
concept
went in and read for the network and I
got the part and then right after that
show sort of dropped Hellboy 2 dropped
so it was a really good year 2007. sons
of our Anarchy I mean one of the
greatest shows of all time I think
what's interesting too Ryan's I'm glad
you came in here because sometimes like
you're a badass on there you know like
you're such a badass that was just
acting yeah no but then so sometimes
we'll get guys in here where I'll be
fans of them then you know from TV or
movies they come in you're like oh it's
you're nothing like those guys well yeah
that that's right they get the eyeliner
on dude you seem to know you did tap
into something because that guy as as
that show goes on your character is so
bad I can't believe it like just willing
to do anything and that is probably how
those you know the leaders of criminal
organizations really are what would then
when they were creating that was there
any sort of conversation or connection
to the actual biker gangs
oh my God I mean the the the the the
best thing that Kurt Sutter did when he
was before he even started writing the
series
was he went up to uh Northern Cali and
hung out with the Hells Angels and
immersed himself in in their world
because he you know every time we had
ever seen a depiction of uh
biker clubs they were always
one-dimensional they were always fat
guys with beards you know spitting and
you know
filling up women yeah and pissing in you
know public and you know like and Kurt
wanted to create a family drama
you know that happened to take place in
this world but he really wanted to
create a a the hierarchy of
you know who's who in the club you know
what does it mean to be the president
what does it mean to be the
sergeant-at-arms all this stuff
um and what does it mean with regard to
your enemies you know the other clubs
around where there's all these turf wars
so he went up there and he spent like
you know at least a month or two just
immersing himself in the world and when
he came back that's when he started
writing so I think the thing that one of
the things that people responded to was
the authenticity was the fact that this
wasn't a one-dimensional kind of world
this was a bunch of very nuanced kind of
like really
weirdly connected relationships you know
who the queen was who the old lady was
you know like what it meant to raise a
family what it meant when you put on the
the the cut you know
um what your responsibilities were
because this was a very very well
crafted subculture
of guys
most of the bikers in in the United
States especially in the 50s
were either fought in the World War II
or the Korean War yeah and they came
back to an ungrateful nation and they
said We Were Heroes man we [__] put
our lives on the line for you and you
know you're treating us like we're you
know like like well like you know we're
homeless like where you know so [__] you
we're going to create our own little
subculture and we're gonna have our own
little you know um uh rules of the road
and we're gonna live off the grid and
that's how the Hell's Angels in a lot of
these original clubs started yeah
they're all very patriotic guys who who
realized that they were coming back to
uh
not not the most grateful of situations
yeah I was I was doing a spot the Laugh
Factory and I see I'd read all the books
on biker gangs I know my biker gangs and
I see this group of biker gangs in the
back I'm at the Laugh Factory
like yeah a good amount of them I see
them in their patches I won't say what
gang it is but I recognize the logo I'm
like oh [__] man bike games so I get off
stage I'm waiting for my car outside
they come out they follow me out and I'm
like oh when I was a UFC fighter I was
supposed to do this the parents in um
Colorado Springs and my manager calls me
goes you can't go like what do you mean
I can't go it was a paid gig and I have
a lot of money back then I'm like what
do you mean I can't go guys there
there's a there's a biker gang meeting
at Hell's Angel meeting and one of their
enforcers put a bounty on you he says he
can beat you up like what he can fight
you yeah you he wants to fight me I'm
like I don't want to be part of that
he's like it's the the sheriff called
and said he can't go it's not worth the
risk so I'm like all right whatever so I
thought maybe there's when I'd walk out
on the street you know Sunset of I'm
like oh hopefully they're not trying to
fight me they're all out there and
they're fans and my first question I
said I go hey man I'm not even trying to
overstep here I go but I was I love Sons
of Anarchy I was like how realistic was
that he's like pretty spot-on man one
guy was pretty spot-on man do you ever
get encroached by any of the Hell's
Angels any of these guys well while the
show was on you know we only we only
work like
four months out of the year to do the
show
so we had like seven months to ourselves
and you know wherever we went around the
around the not just the country but the
world Canada everywhere when if if the
biker gang biker clubs heard that we
were around they will always invite us
to sit down and and they wanted to show
us their appreciation that's pretty cool
so we really got like the endorsement of
the real deal guys which well you played
it like you see again human like that
you played it that that's you just you
do this subtle thing and I I don't know
how you approach that role but
I would say this a lot of times I see
people playing bad guys and I just go
like this I look at the actor and I go
you don't think like a bad guy and you
never have and in fact and you don't
know any bad guys so your plan you're
playing someone you saw in a film
somewhere
that wasn't the case with you you were
playing what what I would say probably
you know it's it was almost like your
character was a guy who's trying to get
from point A to point B
if you had to take some shortcuts he was
going to take some shortcuts but he was
getting the point B and you rooted for
him is that how you looked at that how
did you play how do you play a bad guy
how what are you thinking first of all
are you even thinking he's a bad guy
well you kind of know yeah what
position he he he occupies in in terms
of the overall story right and he's you
know you can't help but say yeah okay
I'm playing the villain yeah
but you have to that's that's where the
judgment completely has to get thrown
out you can as an actor Ever judge the
person that you're about to play
you simply have to understand him
and the thing that I like to do
with uh characters that have a kind of a
muddy relationship with
with uh fitting into society
that's how I would describe uh some of
the villains I've played you know
is
I really want to know what made him like
that
I want to know what happened to them
that made their psychology psychological
wiring
muddy
and and uh a little bit toward the dark
side
and then the minute I embraced that
there's a sympathetic kind of a quality
regardless of how what how bad the
things he does are I think this is the
thing that scarcity does so well in his
movies you know you watch Robert De Niro
and Goodfellas or Joe Pesci and
Goodfellas you love them yeah no but
they're [__] evil I mean they just
like they're ruthless we had Sammy the
bull gravano on this podcast and Sammy
said when he was a kid he was dyslexic
and the kids used to make fun of him and
then they call them dumb
and so he goes I'm dumb all I got is the
street and it started like that and he
goes the one thing I do have though is
I'll fight anybody and I'll never give
up you got to kill me and that's how the
older guy said this kid's like a bull
he's fighting three dudes at one time
right he was so angry because he felt he
was obviously very intelligent but felt
dumb because he was told he was dead
because he was dyslexic right and that
that that I'm human yeah and that that
sort of uh affirmation from these these
gangsters in the town the guys who
everybody looked up to he went I want I
want to be this guy yeah and he was here
for an hour you're like man he's all
right and you're like oh he killed 17
people yeah yeah but like you said like
you can't help he's got a sense of humor
he's got he's Charming you know and and
you will see a human side of his him
yeah but he's also a soldier right and
when he was working for the organization
if he had to kill you you were going
well that's what good acting does right
it's like even with the Jeffrey Dahmer
series on Netflix yep they were saying
how people would fall in love with
Jeffrey Dahmer this horrible serial
killer yeah but the actor was so damn
good he's from American Horror Story my
favorite yeah he's so good you're like
oh I feel bad for him like Anthony
Hopkins this is insane oh my God yeah
yeah that's a perfect example of like
God how holy [__] this is my favorite
character in the whole thing and he eats
people he's like he's a hero they made
a Pablo Escobar the guy was so good
people are buying Pablo Escobar shirts
and merchandise he's in love with it
like that's a terrorist my ex-wife was
like I was crying when he died I was
like okay you don't need people he
killed he was the worst human being I
know but he was so Noble because he was
willing to kill everybody for his wife
I'm like oh Jesus Christ you would have
married the guy and I would have been
they would they would have sent my head
they would have mailed my head to you
yeah my girl were watching it and she's
like he's so people just don't get him
he was like Robin Hood
uh
there there is there are certain Givens
that come with leadership
if you're like Pablo Escobar is the head
you know there's nobody above him that
means he's really intelligent yeah
smarter than anybody else in the room
yep and probably more Charming than
anybody else correct even though he he's
able to and you know the I used to have
these long discussions with Kurt Sutter
about Clay Morrow you know the guy I
played in in sons and I said how is he
able to
switch gears the way he does how is he
able to be such a great husband
and so
um benevolent and loving
to to the group and then
just turn on a dime and do things that
are completely diabolical he says the
one thing you learn how to do when you
when you grow up in a rough way
and you know the premise was that clay
served in the Vietnam War you know he
had he had like tattoos all over them
that you know identified the fact that
he you know
he ran down Terror on people as a
soldier those guys learn how to
compartmentalize one minute there this
and the next minute they're this and
it's all it's it's not a question of
which one you are it's a question of
which one you need to be at any given
bipolar you're a bipolar a sinner a
saint everything in between that's that
is what human beings are Tony Soprano
The Genius of that show was that they he
was a guy running two families his own
family in a crime family and he could he
could order a hit and then yell at his
son for using the f word in the house at
the same time right but then go to
therapy and then go to therapy so you
just go I'm in I'm in with this guy and
the great writers this is why you know
my I'm mystified by because I can't
write yeah
um but the great writers are able to
to not march to any particular Paradigm
you know they understand that life is is
funky and the complex and the villain is
complex and funky and he's got a good
side and you you know anytime you see a
gray movie like okay remember King of
New York with Christopher Walken yeah
there was there was he makes a speech
he's the bad guy but he goes I'm not
your problem I'm just a businessman yeah
you know all that time I was wasting in
jail well it just got worse yeah you
know that's why when you get these great
writers back to work
that's good wrap it up Ron uh how how
does this how do we how do you guys move
the ball forward getting this strike
done with well so I can we're not in
control
you know that's one of the tragedies of
the whole thing is that you know it
takes two sides to come back to the
table and and you know make it make an
agreement
but if you're negotiating with people in
bad faith who are in bad faith who who
have an agenda to not come back to the
table
because it's in their best interests to
hurt the other side or to streamline
some of the mistakes they made in their
business model so that they can say if
the strike goes on long enough we no
longer have to have this relationship
with this particular guy that's called
Force measure the strike has canceled
out a lot of the contracts that these
streamers had with artists do they want
to kill the union is that what they're
trying to do they've always wanted to
kill the union yeah they they cannot
stand organized Labor organized I mean
no industry has has embraced organized
labor in the history of the United
States organized labor has always been a
struggle yeah almost you know how many
so here's a stat for you how many how
many uh workers in this country are part
of a labor union what do you think what
the percentage would be it's pretty
amazing just not entertainment across
the board across the board that's about
a third of what it was
25 years it's seven percent
seven percent how about that seven it
used to be 21 that's right and now it's
well it's just so they're winning
they're winning yeah they're winning oh
yeah their agenda's work again it's like
yes because
so so who do you know who really and I
make a good living
but who do you know who can actually
save money and I mean enough money to
not worry for the next year Elon I don't
know anybody I mean I I know we know
some really rich people but for the most
part you and I make a great living but
saving money in Los Angeles
the [__] out of here now it doesn't help
that I have alimony and child support
and I pay that gladly and and all that
but you know
I always think to myself I'm very lucky
I've done well in this business but and
there are a lot of people that I mean
the struggle is very real it's it's it
is what it is it's like it doesn't seem
to be getting better the only good thing
the strike did was allow the Ron free
time to come on this stupid show well I
would have made time no matter what bro
I'll take it I would have walked on
[__] class
for fighter and the kids
man if you want to storm Netflix I'll be
your first call man I know those actors
aren't exactly this is a big day for me
where do you live do you live in L.A or
do you live in Pasadena oh you do all
right well that's a that's a drive my
brother yeah that's a good drive I have
really really good air conditioning in
my car and great music so is that what
you do in the car did you listen to
music I listen to music yeah what kind
of music it's this playlist that I've
been developing for the last 60 years
are you a musician my father and my
brother were both professional drummers
wow
wow but I never had the discipline to be
to to to practice like you need to
practice
to become a great musician so I had to
choose a creative
outlet that required no discipline and
no Talent so that's why I became an
actor where did you grow up in New York
Washington Heights I know Washington
Heights yeah yeah it's a cool area
actually it still is yeah it's it's
actually nicer now than it is than it
was when I was growing up there because
it's kind of like uh
it's it you know there's so few areas in
New York City where a young family can
start out so Washington Heights has this
kind of
not gentrification but a lot of you know
young families can still afford to get
like a three-bedroom apartment up there
that's right whereas the rest of the
city is like when you were a kid how
often would you go to Manhattan very
very rarely right it's expensive it was
like it was like it was like going to a
different city that's right you know
that's right and we stayed if you were
in the Bronx you stay in the Bronx if
you were in the Bronx that was that was
what you did
on the Bronx
underneath an elevated I IRT subway line
was fieldston bath and Tennis Club
amazing yeah it was a small patch of
grass swimming pool
some Cabanas and a bunch of [__] Jews
playing piano
and Mahjong the women were playing all
the time but guys sounds like a good
time that's a good time they had tennis
courts they had basketball courts they
had they had a swimming pool they had
you know they had dances and stuff and
this was my this was my country club you
know you get older and and uh you start
to just really enjoy being a spectator
and just shooting the [__] just sitting
back and stuck I thought I have the
energy for anymore but since I mean it
has a picket line going I said I don't
know I can't [__] walk 73 I'm not
making a sign but I'm leaving I'm
leaving that to the yeah
of course
I'll come on podcasts yeah yeah go take
a piss you love this he's so wrapped up
with this and I love seeing you like
this we'll have athletes we'll have
everybody you come on and he's like this
you're quiet and you're just going like
this I take it in it's so great the
athletes there's no mystery there's no
even other actors but you got you got a
real
you gotta real
you got a real
you got a guy I might go that far but
you're glad you're grounded you're
grounded in a tradition that's uh well
I'm grounded that's for sure you want a
rapid B go take a pee and we'll return
properly
yeah
look at him holding his pee he's a big
boy right there yeah he's more than I do
yeah that's a lot he peed when I first
got here and now he's peeing again I
don't even have to pee that much big
body small small bladder small that's
what happened small dick too probably I
don't have to say it but it's got small
hands I'm not going to get into it poor
guy well I got big feet and you know
what that means right you know what that
means big understanding that's that's
big socks big socks apparent things
that's right that's probably worth the
board over here these guys are and
they've been trusted I've never seen him
before this is the first the first time
no these these these are our chin has
been with us for this is the beginning
this is the salt of the earth over here
George George was a fan of the show
and he lost how many how much weight I
lost all together 260 pounds
less than 151 pounds and my lowest was
190. listening to the podcast and this
kid we gave him an intern Brennan did
and he's and now he's just been
indispensable indispensable yeah I get
to live to dream make funny little clips
that's a lot of weight to lose bro oh
yeah it took like
two years but just diet exercise six
days a week I had an MMA fight when I
came to care yeah she fought yeah really
I didn't win but I had a fight got
choked you won though you won you won
the big war yeah right I won life yeah
you won the big one you won the big
award
and if it means anything when I come
home from work I play the Call of Duty
zombies that you voice
it means a lot it's
it means a lot anytime anybody you know
like uh anytime anybody tells me that
they you know they've seen something of
mine or they they've watched something
mine or they you know like
like
you know I
I
I'm not blowing smoke or or being
falsely humble or anything like that I
don't I just think of myself as a dude I
don't think of myself as
well as as
you know as a celebrity yeah you know
and uh when I hear like hey I spent a
little time watching this thing and
you're like oh wow that's tell me more
yeah I can't I can't I can't you know I
I'm the same way I I get like I'll be in
the airport I get recognizing I don't
let him go I'm that guy
I'm I'm I'm just like thank you very
much and I'll answer questions I'll sit
there and talk I'm not I've never been
cool I've never gotten over that
conference oh dude I do the first time I
was a first day of show I ever did was a
show called Mad TV I was part of this
the original cast and I came back to New
York after my first season and I got
recognized for the first time
my in fact my buddy got my buddy we're
in Central Park my buddy gets to
interrupted because the guy comes over
to take a picture with me it was 1997 I
go I look at my boys I go guys sorry
it's different now
I'm Captain America it was the [__]
Will Sasso was he on that Will was on
the season after me okay that's my he's
a dear friend and he's done this show a
ton of time oh I bet he has the funniest
his podcast the dude he's a genius he's
a genius
he's a genius funniest person we know oh
my God he's a genius biggest castle I've
never seen anybody that funny or he can
do anything anytime his whole clothing
not only is he funny but he he seems to
have every fact
at his disposal he's brilliant he's so
well read and he's so well informed yeah
I love will how do you know you worked
with him he used to work out at Gold's
Gym with me and uh not with me but I
used to see him did he just do calf
raises that's Muay Thai trainer Harold
yeah Harold Harold taught me the Box
isn't it great I took Carol's tooth out
get the [__] out of here he was he'd
wear two different colored shoes he was
teaching yeah exactly Harold that's my
face next to his calf look at the size
of his [__] massive caps that's a
bull heart was this a Gold's Gym in
Venice
no in uh in Hollywood cawanga
yeah I used to work out there yeah it
was a game until the pandemic I worked
out yeah and you used to work and and so
you do a little boxing
so I decided to you know how Harold and
I became tight just from like
bullshitting on the floor this was a
Muay Thai it was a world champion Muay
Thai guy and he was and what was his
name Jewish guy Jewish guy Harold
Diamond Harold he was in the he was in
the salon movies he was sasso's trainer
but he was a legit fighter he actually
fought in uh what's the center in what's
that in in the uh Bangkok in Thailand
yeah the big uh Stadium yeah I know what
you're talking about yeah anyway but uh
yeah so go on so no no I mean so I
decided
I decided yeah I wanted a you know box a
couple of times a week and and and and
and so I hired Harold to to be my boxing
trainer up up in goals upstairs in the
second floor
and uh there he is and um
we were going along really good and then
one day he was teaching me this
combination
and he said okay let's see it before he
had got a chance to put his hand up
and I took his [__] tooth out that
was the last lesson I had with him
do you still I'm still getting done are
you still getting insurance no and do
you still trained he didn't he didn't
have do you still train or no he didn't
have dental obviously yeah
um no he he actually moved to Bangkok
[__] like all muscle and what we were at
a party at sasso's house and he he uh he
grabbed me around the waist and did this
thing where I was like Jesus he's like
you know and he would he lift his shirt
up and he just had dinner rolls and just
muscle just and he had so many opinions
about nutrition yeah and it was a very
he was a very colorful dude color sounds
like you're lucky Ron doesn't take your
tooth out bud yeah listen my hands are
always up my hands we have to my head
never stops man I used to be
yeah training Ron it's a big day for me
man I'm glad you came in brother I am
too man you know I was like uh because I
said to Rob
because he set this up you know the guy
who did yeah and uh I said so what do I
need to know I mean he said well it's
kind of sports oriented I said yeah but
I don't follow any sports except golf I
said they're probably not going to
[__] want to talk about golf I like
golf she said well I don't know what to
tell you then maybe you don't want to do
the show after all I said no you know
what we'll make it work we don't talk
about yeah it's weird we call it Sports
what a pleasure yeah we're not a sports
it's been a great conversation yeah
you're the best man I hope the strike
stuff gets figured out I really do well
in the meantime you know you you are um
you're important and uh this is
something that people have to realize
it's you know anybody who's fighting the
good fight and in the business of
original self-expression and who holds
the bar as high as you do
um sometimes you don't feel like you're
making a difference but you do make a
difference man and that that's I know
you feel like just a dude as you were
talking about but no you're not you're
not and and you're a sage you know in
your own way and that's that's kind of
what comes with being if it comes down
to it you guys need some muscle you got
my number
yeah hell yeah if you've got somebody
who's good in a wheelchair man
and you know I'll be like this I know
we're wrapping this up yeah but we don't
have to but I wanna I wanna I wanna we
we were getting on to something a second
ago
and what I realized about the the the
with the onset of the strike and with
the fact that I started realized like
we're living in an upside down Twisted
world where people what people are being
shoved down their throats is just
strictly false the one percent is one
percent and they got us bullshitted into
the fact that they control everything
and and it's just
you know if if they were making the
world a better place God bless
sign me up right but if they're
if they're devaluing
the most beautiful things about living
in this life
um in order for them to Gaslight us into
thinking that we can't live without them
then we got a problem
and I started thinking about
um
uh
what did I say what did I start thinking
about
I started thinking about
how
the narrative
absolutely has to be changed
and how the the people who made you know
who were real Maga make America great
again you know what that was that was
the middle class and you know why the
middle class
happened
is because of labor unions like the
minute
labor got the idea in the 30s
against
threats of [__] being killed and
violence that they needed to organize in
order to get a civilized Working Day and
and and it's kind of a salary structure
where they could raise kids
and retire with dignity that's the
slogan of the middle class and you know
retirement that's that's what made
America great
you know well the idea that you had a
future that if you played by the rules
and that if you worked hard you could
you could create a better life for your
kids and a future where you could take a
breath where you could catch your
[__] breath man so when you mention
the fact that there's only seven percent
of all the workers in the United States
that that are members of labor union
that's the problem and then you look at
you know
[__] Amazon that you know that that
won't let you unionize and Starbucks
that won't let you unionize and then you
look at the fact that
for the
like I came up in the 60s I had [__]
The Beatles Martin Luther King John
Kennedy Robert Kennedy Bob Dylan Malcolm
X we were [__] Gonna Change the World
everybody that was from 17 to 29 was
engaged bro
and now I'm looking at a bunch of
[__] 17 to 29 year olds that have all
the energy in the world all the idealism
in the world and absolutely nothing to
believe in because there's no Direction
the enemy they're looking at their
[__] phone the enemy feels like a
machine though the enemy feels like it's
invisible we don't know people don't
know where to strike they don't so so
you talk about let's give them a
Direction that's what they need is
directions that's what you have to do
because the problem is that right now
it's what I said most kids don't even
know where or how they fit into a future
a future that offers the blockchain
nanotechnology robots AI a future that
that is going to replace human
expression and the human machine with a
better quote-unquote better machine so
so you know even with unions and stuff
what they'll tell you is hey technology
is going to take your job anyway
and this is what so so whether that's
true or not I don't want to live in a
world of machines
I want to live in a world of people who
are so
you know one of the things you love
about cars is like Ferraris in those
cars is yeah dude the the but the the
detail this this thing the the
craftsmanship that goes into that the
Artistry that goes into the body yes
it's more than just convenience it's
more than just abundance it's not
convenient there is something you gain
from cooking your own meal picking up
that tomato and finding the right one
that's been ripened on a vine there's
something about that process that takes
a long time to make an amazing meal and
serving that to your family and sitting
around and taking the time to eat if you
think you can replace that with a
machine then good luck with that good
luck with that but there but there is a
segment of our society that does yes and
that and and that segment of society is
rewarded with with inordinate amounts of
wealth and inordinate amounts of power
and I'm telling you that that sliver of
society that is operating on that level
of cynicism on the fact that there
there's nothing worth
no no part of humanity that's worth
dying for other than greed and wealth
they are very much in the minority yes
so what I have you know just to wrap all
this up because we've been talking a
little bit about the strike and about
barriers and other things
is
I'm going to spend the rest of my life
figuring out a way
to engage the guys from 17 to 29 into
having something to [__] fight for
and that thing is going to be dignity
that thing is going to be Humanity that
thing is going to be individual respect
that thing is going to be a return to
the thing like I'm not powerless in fact
I'm just the opposite I can [__] tell
these guys how shit's gonna go
that's a movement sign me up and and we
will always be here for you to come on
here that's a movement bro and I think I
think I think that yeah it's one thing
to be a part of the entertainment
industry and we're going on strike now
but we are just a symptom of a very
bigger Melody yep and that that is the
devaluation of things that are precious
yeah and the devaluation of the
individual and his ability to [__]
reach the moon and to know the
difference between a technology that can
cure cancer and cure diabetes
or replace Humanity yeah and Mankind
that's yeah just because that's a great
distinction just because that technology
is out there doesn't mean you have to
use it for the most diabolical means
unless all you care about is greed yeah
and I I I particularly feel like we we
need to just do everything we can to
change the narrative to say sorry
[__] you don't win you don't
win I'm not all you do is you try to
make me feel small and you know what
that's [__] that's gaslighting bro
yep so you don't win
and you're gonna get tough if it means
creating a movement
where labor where the little guy you
know becomes the straw that stirs the
drink again
sign me up let's go that's a good thing
worth fighting for exactly that's a good
that's a good monologue to end on yep
you see what I mean
on Netflix right now no no no you take
it easy that's a big truck I had Ron
Perlman said oh I'm with Ron I never I
never mentioned the n-word
never mention the n-word uh speaking of
being creative spoken on there this
Thursday Friday Saturday Spokane comic
Club one of my faves I'll probably be
staying Coeur d'Alene but either way
Spokane Washington September 21st 23rd
I'll be there skank Festival yes hey
Genesee Theater I'll see you
um I'll see you at the Genesee Theater
September why does it say oh funny but
I'm already done where's Genesee there
we go oh there we go Sunday Waukegan
Illinois Sunday I'll see you at the
Genesee Theater let's go steal some
tickets September 24th 7 P.M can't wait
skank Fest after that Comedy Zone
Greensboro North Carolina October 6th
and 7. come get some Brian callan.com
Ron prom Ron we love you you're awesome
pleasure bro thank you so much WoW
appreciate it a breath of fresh air one
of my faves we're out